the reason my company has been
successful in terms of this is because
of an idea meritocratic decision-making
a process by which you can get the best
ideas you know what's an idea
meritocracy an idea meritocracy is to
get the best ideas that are available
out there and to work together with
other people and the team to achieve
that so if we can look around a little
bit longer
the idea of an idea meritocracy it's
fascinating but especially because it
seems to be rare
not just in companies but in society so
there's a lot of people on Twitter and
public discourse and politics and so on
that are really stuck in certain sets of
ideas whatever they are so when you're
confronted with it with an idea that
said that's different than your own
about a particular topic what kind of
process do you go through mentally are
you arguing through the idea with the
person sort of present is almost like a
debate or do you sit on it and consider
the world sort of empathetically if this
is true then what is that war look like
does that world make sense and so on so
what's the process of considering those
conflicting ideas I'm gonna answer that
question but after saying first
implement implicit in your question is
it's not common okay what's common
produces only common results okay
so don't judge yes anything that is good
based on whether it's common because
you're on it's only going to give you
common results if you want unique you
have a unique approach yes okay and so
that art of thoughtful disagreement is
the is the capacity to hold two things
in your mind at the same time the G I
think this makes sense and then saying
I'm not sure it makes sense and then try
to say why does it make sense and then
to triangulate with others so if I'm
having a discussion like that and I work
myself through and I'm not sure then I
have to do that in a good way
so I always
attention for example what let's start
off what does the other person know
relative to what I know so if a person
has a higher expertise are things I'm
much more inclined to ask questions I'm
always asking questions if you want to
learn you're asking questions you're not
arguing okay you're taking in you're
assessing when it comes in to you does
that make sense so you're learning
something are you getting epiphanies and
so on and I try to then do that if the
conversation it as we're trying to
decide what is true and we're trying to
do that together and we see truth
different then I might even call in
another really smart capable person and
try to say what is true and how do we
explore that together and you go through
that same thing so I would I said I
describe it as having open mindedness
and assertiveness at the same time that
you can simultaneously be open minded
and take in with that curiosity and then
also be assertive and say but that
doesn't make sense why would this be the
case and you do that back and forth
you